[Music]
Trick or Treat River babes
I'm your witchy host Liana Galera and
this is your Sweetwater secrets after
shell for episode 404 chapter 61
Halloween now in honor of Riverdale's
first ever Halloween episode and the
fact that today's episode of Sweetwater
has landed exactly on Halloween I've
spooked up the set a little bit
basically I just took all my witches
council props and put them here yeah
today I'll be going over all of your
haunted hisses and kisses to start
commenting or tweet me with your
thoughts plus guess what I was the only
person on set when the cast was filming
this episode so I'll be bringing you
interviews with KJ kami Lily Cole
Madeline and Vanessa spilling some
wicked behind-the-scenes secrets but
first let's go over all of the creepiest
moments of the night with the blue and
gold breakdown wow just wow you guys
this episode was insane well it started
off with the fact that everyone was
receiving VHS tapes that had hours worth
of footage of their front door honestly
the only thing scarier than this is the
fact that everyone in Riverdale
apparently still has their VCRs anyways
let's start off with the most important
twist of the night and that was Jughead
story line at Stonewall prep now out of
the five students that actually seem to
attend that pretentious school four of
them seemed to hate him so they drugged
him and then nailed him into a coffin
now eight panic attacks in one nap later
Jughead was rescued from the coffin but
instead of running away from those
preppy Psychopaths he went back to his
room to see that Marmaduke is gone again
but wait it gets a whole lot worse
because in what appeared to be a
flash-forward Betty and FP were standing
in the coroner's office and they pulled
back the sheet to reveal jugheads dead
body what the actual F is going on we
are gonna come back to that meanwhile
Archie was still concerned with getting
kids off of the mean
streets of Riverdale so he and Munroe
suited up and some interesting looks and
decided to throw a Halloween party at
their community center after that
lowlife Dodger crashed the party and
caused some chaos
Archie decided he was ready to fight
crime on a full-time basis yeah
now as for his ladylove Veronica well
she had a pretty rough night working
that solo shift at pops so a creepy man
came in asking for her to make him a
meal so he could get back on the road
but just as it looked like her night was
going to be sweet as pie Ronny realized
that the man was a killer who goes after
cuties who can cook she dashed into la
bonne nuit and then she used her extra
stash of alcohol to start a bad-guy
bonfire over at thistle house Joanie was
understandably creeped out by the fact
that Cheryl is talking to her dead
brother's corpse so after Tony told
Cheryl it's time to Ribery Jason's body
the ladies discovered in the ultra
creepy doll hanging around the house
Cheryl was convinced it was the ghost of
JJ so they had a blossom family seance
but it turns out the spirit was coming
through as Julian the triplet that
Cheryl absorbed in the womb no I'm not
making this up by the end of the episode
Jason's body was back in the house and
Tony is now severely creeped out and it
looks like they're being haunted by a
doll as for Betty well our blonde beauty
was babysitting jellybean on Halloween
night when she started receiving creepy
phone calls from someone claiming to the
blood be the black hood Charles
conveniently showed up offered his FBI
services and claimed the calls were
coming from Polly and then he started
spying on Betty yeah so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna reiterate all
that for you
Archie thinks he's gonna be a superhero
Shawn he's being haunted by a hideous
doll Betty's half brother's a total
creep Veronica set a man on fire and
Jughead was locked in the coffin and now
seems like he's dead cool
to make you feel better here's a mashup
of my interviews with the cast talking
all about their Halloween how-tos and
thoughts about their on-screen costumes
he found out we were finally after four
seasons getting a Halloween episode what
was your reaction I was excited because
I think Halloween is the perf
obviously holiday Riverdale so I'm
surprised it took this long to do it it
just it worked out perfectly with the
dates that we're airing this season so
it's gonna air right around Halloween
and and I think we're really embracing
it and going for it
it's fun it's really fun let's do it
what is it like filming this episode
seeing your Jones Cooper home all decked
out and fall you know I don't really
spend too much time in this house during
this episode hmm I spend time in a very
different wooden box it's really funny
let me out now
but it's nice I didn't yeah I was I was
saying I didn't really take the Jones
for a house full of decorators but I
suppose you know season for little
changes what other explanation could
there possibly be you know I'm actually
surprised because I didn't think Cheryl
and telling you I'd do Halloween their
way they're doing it but I'm not gonna
spoil exactly what that is however we do
like obviously get very dressed up and
things take a very strange turn but a
very Cheryl blossom mask turn every
blossom you turn there being fussier
than usual
how does Archie do Halloween and how
does JJ do Halloween KJ doesn't really
celebrate Halloween because he's 22
years old something I got into it as a
kid growing up and you gentleman it's
not that that's not that big of a deal
you know your total badass right hammy
is very lazy when it comes to Halloween
I don't like putting any effort into
anything but sometimes sometimes it
works out Lilly and I dressed up as
Pedro and Napoleon last year and that
was really fun but that took like a day
to put together so that I'm okay with
Veronica however I think she would put
in a little bit more effort not
necessarily in this episode because
she's a little hung up on some other
stuff but I feel like normally she would
like to dress up for Halloween yeah she
seems like that kind of girl I like to
think so
growing up I was you know I was I went
out with my friends I went
trick-or-treating but I also now these
days I spend the whole month of October
watching horror movies like as many as I
can
and then on actual Halloween I'm usually
working so it's not as exciting happy
Halloween to me yeah
really love Halloween I always go really
big because Halloween is one truly one
of the only times that all of us can go
out as a cast in full costume and have
all that anonymity and basically be able
to do whatever we want without people
knowing who we are so we usually go
pretty big okay happy Halloween
kiss what was your reaction when you
found out what Archie's costume is what
can you tell the fans comes from some of
the old comics what he's wearing my life
so I'm not saying oh yeah pure heart the
powerful we look ridiculous I mean
excitement excitement also very perfect
for our characters I feel like and like
I didn't know how far we were gonna go
with these outfits I wasn't sure about
costumes it's gonna do when they never
disappoint I mean like they really went
all out with these boys says look I
haven't seen this version of Harley
Quinn before kids from the original
Harley Quinn costume did I like I really
like it home is right in the world
she is Laurie Strode from the original
Halloween Jamie Lee Curtis is character
in Helena okay I'm sorry
this is that's real badass for Lily it's
like I I felt like a grown woman wearing
wearing that costume I was like wow my
hair is down I have like these nice
jeans I'm like wow I look like a
grown-up and my hair is not in a bony
tail but but I I made Roberto add a line
where I explain who Laurie Strode is
because I didn't want people to be like
why is she dressed like she's from the
70s like with no explanation so I was
like I think we need to clarify and also
for those younger viewers who maybe do
not know well I didn't know Laurie
Strode by her nails and Laurie Strode
and then I was like oh right obviously
but like I needed like I was like I
think we need a little bit of an
explanation I loved being on set for
that episode and I would also love to
know if any of you river babes are
dressing up as your favorite Riverdale
characters tonight let me know in the
comments and now let's take a quick look
at the brief but booty-ful romance
moments of the night with seven seconds
in heaven now due to the fact that our
Riverdale ian's were either being hunted
haunted or harassed
we were pretty light on the love this
week but we do have a few moments so
let's take a look we started off with
some really sweet phallus near kisses
some Shoni sexiness that was rude
interrupted we got a teeny tiny bit of
VAR Chee cuddles and then Buckhead had a
phone call so let's switch over to the
best and worst moments of the night with
hisses and kisses all right so I want to
start off with hisses - the fact that
Cheryl keeps lying to Tony now I
understand that Cheryl's going through a
lot and that we need to address her
mental health right now but this isn't
the first time that Cheryl has admitted
to lying to her girlfriend and I know it
bothered quite a few of you - on Twitter
a true beastie tweeted kisses to Cheryl
for gaslighting Tony hisses - mr. honey
for his comments - Kevin and Reggie
kisses - jellybean for the prank she
pulled on Betty and kisses - bug head
for being adorable yes all great points
and you know what I also want to add
hisses - mr. honey because honestly what
is your problem dude yes I understand
they were trying to kind of destroy your
office a little bit but he tormented
sweet baby Kevin and then completely
destroyed
Reggie's self-confidence that was really
brutal to watch and then his car
Reggie's car just cannot seem to catch a
break honestly poor Reggie right now
he's been through a lot right now and
you guys are giving me some really great
comments Frank narf says hisses - Kevin
for his downward spiral I think that
Kevin clearly is still going through a
lot he's got a lot of farming lingering
feelings
he misses fangs there's a whole lot of
F's in there you can make that little
joke yourself I'm not going there but I
know where your mind is going okay son
tix said his sister Cheryl for hiding a
dead body in her basement yes but I feel
like the biggest hisses right now are
when Cheryl admitted to Tony that she
was trying to creep her out by placing
that doll around the house that is not
okay at all whole bunch of it is not
okay but that was quite bizarre
Snickers six said hisses to them
continuously torturing Betty it's so
hard to watch honestly I feel like they
keep torturing buddy because she can
take it she's a tough cookie she's great
but yes I will admit that every single
time her cellphone rings or the Cooper
or Jones house rings I'm like uh it's
for Betty and it's someone who's trying
to torment her it's very sad um
Gabby edit says all the kisses to Fallas
and so was a tweet from Alice's madhouse
and they said kisses - Nana rose Shoni
as poison ivy and Hartley
Veronica kicking ass against a murderer
and hisses - Jughead trapped in the box
Reggie's carbine destroyed Charles means
shady chair Cheryl tricking Tony into
getting Jason's body back yes everyone
has a lot of thoughts on that
yes completely okay we have a comment
from little softy saying hisses -
Charles for listening to bug heads phone
calls just hisses - Charles not even for
for listening to Betty's phone calls
which is creepy and I'm pretty sure
illegal also let's talk about the fact
that like there is no junior FBI program
Betty's right not to trust him and I
hate that just as she's coming around
this is another chick situation and I'm
not here for it
don't like it what possible excuse would
you need to listen in on your sisters
phone calls also while we're at it I
don't know if Polly was the one making
those phone calls I think he might have
lied and said it was coming from Polly
to create division mm-hmm yeah okay we
have a few more texts coming in we have
ameesha a laga said hisses - Veronica
and that lunatics right I mean seriously
yeah Muraki said a man on fire she did
that what if he had not had a lighter
what if he was using his iPhone in the
flashlight she was just doused it and
really strong alcohol I'm not sure thank
goodness she's oh she's quick on her
feet it wasn't a bad storyline it just
wasn't my favorite does that make sense
Go Go Veronica and also like did we
check on this guy is he dead is Lebon
who we burned down is she gonna have
like a fleshy mess to clean up
I don't know I don't know guys just
don't know Kara Castillo said hisses -
Polly for tricking Betty into thinking
that she was talking to the black
once again I'm not sure if it was Paulie
but I am glad that Betty called her a
[ __ ] sorry and put her in her place
because truly Paulie is the worst sister
EVER
I know that most of the people in
Riverdale don't even really have
siblings but Paulie just takes the cake
for being the worst um you also had
mixed feelings on jellybeans prank a lot
of people gave it hisses a lot of people
gave it kisses for scaring the bejesus
out of Betty I thought it was great I
also love the fact that jellybean plays
minecraft get it girl that was like the
most normal line we've had in Riverdale
in a really long time we have another
tweet from at everyday phallus this is
the tweet I was looking for and they
said kisses to phalluses development as
a couple living together and
individually FP being the town's great
sheriff and Alice getting her big break
for being a reporter yes I was so
excited to see they're living together
it makes sense it's her house
but you guys if they don't show us a
phallus kiss I don't know what I'm gonna
do anymore
I talked to ski-in matron at New York
Comic Con and they said they've filmed
it do they keep cutting away from them
I'm not quite sure because I can't
imagine that they didn't kiss at the end
of that scene what do we have to do dude
to be able to witness you showed the
kids kissing all the time I don't know I
don't know okay Michaela Taylor hey girl
said don't hate me but hisses to Tony
for suggesting they read dig up Jason's
body and replace it with the doll I did
not understand her logic there truly I
think that everyone should just be
giving kisses to Tony because she's
putting up with a lot right now and
she's doing it with a slightly creeped
out smile on her face so props to Tony
for not running out of thistle house and
just running away I'm sorry it that
really is some unconditional love there
if you guys have not already watched my
show any interview with Madeline and
Vanessa that we've posted yesterday it's
ten glorious minutes of all just them
talking I know you were gonna like it
watch it it's probably over on the side
over here or over here yeah over here
okay Sutton NYX said I'm being Archie
and
my BFF is being Cheryl oh I love that I
hope you guys have a really fun time
dress up is your favourite Riverdale
characters I feel like I play dress up
every week with you guys so that's why I
went a little off-brand
I feel like I'm sooo bringing up today
and I'm happy about that I would have
loved to Sabrina cross over for this
Halloween episode okay um Kayla Rose
hisses do Charles I knew I didn't trust
him
does anyone trust a newcomer in
Riverdale that's the thing have we ever
had a brand new character that's come in
from seasons 2 on that aren't just made
to be awful they tried to they
introduced Tony and she's the only one
that turned out to be good but then they
tried to have her create issues there's
never just someone who just like comes
in and they're just like hi I'm an
awesome person and love me okay
Andrea Varnado Gomez said hisses - the
fact that bug-head
is yet again apart let them be together
and happy you know Andrea I completely
agree with you because here's the thing
with Jughead at Stonewall prep the
students don't want him there Betty
doesn't want him there jellybean doesn't
want him there so why is Jughead being
like you know where I want to be there I
want to be with all these people who do
not like me and lock me in a coffin and
you know what you know that that
Professor was in on it all why did he
have his phone this is all just very
bizarre they do not want him there why
are you trying to prove something get
away and while we're talking about
Jughead let's take a look again at that
corner scene because I want to really
really analyze it right now because we
had Betty and FP standing over this body
and I just want to yeah right here like
I swear to god guys if we could put it
in slow motion I would
it looks like Jughead but I refuse to
believe that it's Jughead
this is know so you know in the Archie
comics Jughead has I think it's an
identical cousin named sue ped I'm not
making this up I'm like 88% positive and
what I'm saying right now
so what if that's not cole sprouse
playing Jughead what
that's dylan sprouse playing soup egg
and that jug just has an identical
cousin out there
you think it's crazy but it's not
because apparently Cheryl has absorbed
her triplet which leads us to another
tweet right now from oh snap it's Mike
and they wrote hisses to Julian or
Cheryl or are they technically the same
person how does this make total
riverdale sense and also be pure
insanity kisses to Veronica for fighting
off a serial killer
his sister Charles or whoever he is
because why you listening to phone calls
hey yeah once again Charles your big
creeps but share will apparently
absorbed her triplet sure how do they
know it's Cheryl who absorbed it why why
not JJ what would have Jason absorbed it
also why is this a thing I I'm not quite
sure hey we're gonna take a couple more
comments because I just don't have a lot
of thoughts and so do you guys okay
Mariah Swope said his sister Nana rose
for letting all of this happen
Oh No Nana Rose you guys know that Nana
Rose can do whatever she wants
apparently she used to not be able to
walk and now she can Nana Rosa's a
miracle person so she wants to say that
Cheryl absorbed her triplet in the womb
then you know what let's believe man
arose she hasn't done anything wrong
God loved Nana Rose miss friends fan
forever said kins someone please get
Cheryl some help ASAP that girl's and
some dire need for some therapy
I completely agree but it's Riverdale so
I'm not sure if that's ever gonna happen
but yes because if she were to go to a
therapist they would show us that and
then it would turn out that her
therapist is evil so fingers crossed we
get some some help soon okay and Kayla
Rose said hisses to Polly for being her
hisses to Polly for being happy that
Edgar or happy that she was thinking
that she was talking to Edgar
I don't blame Polly for that she was so
brainwashed and even though Edgar
strapped a bomb to her and threatened to
blow her up and then wanted to kill her
she really liked him but also have you
seen Edgar chat Malcolm Maria was fine
so honestly I get where you're coming
from Polly I can't
coming from and you know what I think
we're gonna end it there because this
was a lot this is a big thing big
episode but thank you all so much for
watching today's Halloween episode of
Sweetwater and I'll see you in next
week's after-show for chapter 62 witness
for the prosecution but first please
give this video a like and then hit
subscribe so you never miss an episode
and then head on down to the comments or
tweet me with your spooky thoughts how
are you feeling about Cheryl's brotherly
obsession who do you hate more mr. honey
Charles or Brett hmm and do you really
think Jughead is going to die tell me
everything and have a happy and safe
Halloween river babes
[Music]